[Music]
so you've written a book on the
unspeakable how did you get interested
in this topic what got me interested in
the topic of the limits of language and
inability and unspeakably T was the fact
that so many people report extraordinary
experiences for example in esthetic
contexts or in religious contexts and
what they usually say is something like
they had a feeling that they learned
something very substantial in those
moments for example while listening to a
very moving mala symphony or something
like that but when pressed to say what
it was what the inside consisted in they
find themselves at a lack of words so
they cannot express what it is what the
inside consisted in but the feeling
remains that something very profound was
transmitted in those moments and so I
wanted to I wanted to explore what could
be an explanation for that
metaphysically speaking did you
experience something like that yourself
or did people close to you experience
these unspeakable yeah I think I think
it's a pretty common phenomenon even
though it feels extraordinary but I'm
sure most people know the feeling of
being really overwhelmed in the face of
a piece of art be it a painting or a
piece of poetry or music is also very
very has very very has a strong way of
pushing people into these experiences so
I think it's not something totally
outlandish that you know people haven't
haven't experienced themselves
yeah and how come you talk about
religious irreligious and artistic
experiences what what are the
similarities between the two and the
differences between the two mm-hmm so I
think the similarities between the two
are that they feel extremely meaningful
to the subjects having those experiences
they seem to as I said transport a kind
of content or a kind of ineffable
insight that is impossible to put into
words but at the same time it moves us
profoundly it can even change the way we
see the world the way we look out into
the world I think that's a something
they have in common it's not only in
religious and aesthetic contexts that
people have these experiences so I think
philosophy is a context where people
actually experience mmm pretty
fundamentally changing moments where
they have insights that are perhaps not
easy to express in language I was going
to ask you about how different
philosophers across history from lousy
to Vidkun Stein have thought about the
unspeakable because you touch upon that
in your is that right yes for a lay
audience okay for fellow philosophers
yeah so that's interesting so the the
concept of ineffability shows up over
and over again in the history of
philosophy but it shows up according to
which period we're talking about it
shows up in different contexts so loud
for example in an ancient China he
referred to the Dow as the main sort of
well it's very difficult to define but
as the sort of fundamental principle of
reality and that is also fundamentally
in f war so here the ineffable is
something that is out there in the world
whereas perhaps well who can I think of
Schopenhauer much later on related these
that related the ineffable to
the will which is also a main principle
of reality and he thought that art and
specifically music could put us in touch
with the will with the main principle of
reality but here our experience of this
principle is in a much more personal
context so it's it has been there as a
concept all the time but it has changed
the way it was presented in the context
in which it was presented who are you
closer to in terms of how you see the
ineffable oh that's that's an
interesting question I'm not quite sure
I think both of them got something very
very right
I think the philosopher that influenced
me the most with regard to the NFL was
Adorno he believed that on the one hand
it's philosophies tasks to try and
express the ineffable the essential
truths about reality but at the same
time he believed that language would
necessarily fail doing at doing that so
there was this there is this constant
paradox that we're trying to get at
something with our language while we
already know that we cannot get at it
and I think that's that's what speaks to
me the most why is it philosophy rather
than art or religion like this is the
things that actually provoke the user
these powerful emotions sorry why is it
why is it philosophy that can express
the ineffable rather than art or
religion the sources of the these
feelings there's overwhelming feeling
well I think none of them can express it
I mean certainly philosophy cannot
express the ineffable but what
philosophers do and what I try to do in
my book is to examine the conditions
under which we have ineffable
experiences and what that might tell us
about the underlying metaphysics I think
if anything probably art is a better
expressive medium for f'ing the
ineffable as it were but of course
it's difficult to give a proper
description of how art achieves that
what what aesthetic expression
consistent and then what do you think so
these experiences are quite like
extraordinary in the sense that you know
they get you out of your ordinary life
and routine what is their impact on our
day-to-day lives I think that depends on
what we make of those experiences and
that in turn depends on all kinds of
background concepts we already have so
for example if you're already a
religious person and you have an
experience like that chances are you
going to link it up somehow with your
prior religious beliefs whereas if
you're an atheist then you might come up
with something else I don't know what
that might be I think the the effect
these experiences often have perhaps
particularly in aesthetic context is
that we just see our environments in
different ways and sometimes these
experiences can have really long lasting
effects so yeah and moving on to the
other subject that you mentioned you you
will be talking about later maths and
philosophy and what exactly is your take
on it well how did you become interested
in the philosophy of maths I became
interested in the philosophy of maths
for a number of reasons I think numbers
or mathematical objects in general are
very very interesting objects of study
but one thing I noticed was that
philosophical questions that are being
asked in different areas of philosophy
are very very similar but philosophers
working in these different fields tend
to not really talk to each other very
much and in particular philosophy of
mathematics works in a relatively
isolated way and so only only recently
Philosopher's have started picking up on
parallels between philosophy of maths on
the one hand and ethics for example or
meta ethics on the other hand
and they've started drawing very
interesting analogies between these two
different domains and so that's what I'm
I'm researching and researching the
evidential force of using mathematics as
a conceptual model okay that sounds like
very far removed from you know the daily
kind of experience how did you you know
what I don't even know where like we
start doing something like that um are
you analyzing than mathematics and the
structures are matter of mathematics in
the abstract or the way that applies to
the way we perceive reality so I think
it might be helpful to think about it in
to to illustrate what I'm talking about
to consider how the relationship between
mathematics on the one hand and the
empirical sciences on the other hand has
developed so in ancient Greece
mathematics was considered the highest
form of knowledge knowledge about
eternal forms and so it was as it were
eternal truths that mathematics embodies
whereas the empirical world was a world
of mere opinion we could only form
beliefs about the empirical world but we
could never have actual knowledge about
the empirical world so mathematics and
the empirical world were very very far
removed from one another and that
changed during the times of the
Scientific Revolution when Galileo
coined the term of mathematics being the
language of the book of nature so all of
a sudden science and mathematics Petite
became two sides of the same project as
it were and then later on again the
fourth sort of the fortunes of
mathematics got a lot worse
so during empiricist times in the
nineteenth century mathematics was only
considered a tool for the empirical
sciences and only empirical knowledge
was considered well grounded knowledge
and today we're at a point where
mathematical reality sort of exists
independently of our empirical reality
and there are intersections in the area
of Applied Mathematics
but there is also a large part of
mathematics that is completely
independent from the empirical world and
we use that part of mathematics we use
this idea of mathematics as this unified
whole where all truths are fully
determinate we use that as a model when
we think about other things in our lives
for example when we think about ethics
or metaphysics and philosophy or even
religion we want all these domains to
look as much as possible like
mathematics fully determinate one answer
to every open question etc etc and so
yeah I'm interested in the extent to
which mathematics has influenced our
conceptualization of these different
areas is it problematic that we want
ethics to function like math it is it is
problematic in some sense and it might
actually not be the correct picture of
mathematics anymore so that's that's
also what triggered my interest in this
project that it looks like mathematics
is moving towards a very robustly
pluralistic picture of the mathematical
realm so it turns out that in some in
some area of mathematics notably in set
theory some mathematicians have
suggested that we should give up the
hunt for the the one unique correct
answer to open mathematical questions
and just accept that there are different
mathematical universes in each one in in
each one of which the same mathematical
statement can be sometimes true and
sometimes false and this is an approach
in mathematics that has taken very very
seriously and I'm wondering what that
might mean for other areas of our lives
where we're we're still thinking in
terms of one unified whole and given
that mathematics has always influenced
the way we thought about other aspects
of reality I think also the pluralistic
move in mathematics will have a
long-term effect
so in terms of ethics does that there's
a more pluralist approach to math also
encourage a more pluralist approach to
ethics or a more relativist one a
relativistic one so that's what I'm
thinking about at the moment and I'm my
guess is that yes there might be
connections
I think certainly it might turn out that
we don't need definite answers to all
the questions we're asking it might be
that in order to get along in sort of in
our life together with other human
beings we do need to decide on certain
very fundamental questions but it might
be the case that sort of higher-order
questions we don't need to answer in a
definite way and I think that would
already be a pretty revolutionary result
with that if that's what happened
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you